Oh,
I'm art.
Learn a loud.
I'm a seismologist at the Lamont Doherty
Earth Observatory of Columbia
University.
Uh,
I'm also associate director for the
division of Seismology Geology and
tectonic physics.
Oh,
seismology is a study of earthquakes and
the earth.
Uh,
there are two parts of seismology want
us to actually look in detail at the
earthquakes themselves.
And the other is to use the earthquakes
as a sort of light source for
photographing or imaging the earth
imaging.
The earth is something that we sometimes
call it structural seismology but very
much like a cat scan you might get an a
medical office.
We use the waves generated by
earthquakes to aluminate this internal
structure of the earth.
Uh,
one of the great mysteries of the planet
is what is your Earth made out of?
How does that stuff move?
And seismology is really a remote
sensing tool for us to try to understand
that.
Well,
one of,
one of the wonderful things that has
happened in the earth sciences over the
last 40 years is what we call the theory
of plate tectonics.
And Plate tectonics really is a very
descriptive working hypothesis that
allows us to take diverse sets of
observations and put them together and
see if we can understand how the,
how the planet as a whole works.
Uh,
but plate tectonics really is just a,
a kinematic theory.
What that means is that it really only
describes the motions of the plates,
how fast they move,
uh,
what their boundaries look like and so
on.
Um,
but we really don't know how they move
or what forces them to move.
And to do that,
we really have to penetrate into the
interior of the earth.
Now,
in many ways,
the earth is like a big bubbling pot of
fix soup,
non geologic time.
The earth is really a fluid.
Of course on human time.
It's a rock.
You hit a rock with a hammer and my
crumble and break a,
but on geologic time,
the earth really behaves like a big
melted plastic ball.
And,
uh,
it's the movement of that molten
material,
uh,
that plastic,
that warm plastic material that really
drives the plates,
but we can't observe it directly.
And so we use earthquakes and,
and uh,
what we call structural seismology,
uh,
to image it.
Um,
if you were taking a,
or if you were interested in the
workings of the human body,
uh,
what you would do would be to take a cat
scans or three dimensional images from
time to time to time to get sort of a,
a movie of how the body works.
Well,
that's exactly what we're doing with the
seismology.
We take cat scans,
time,
and it gives us some indication of,
of what's going on.
Uh,
of course,
uh,
we can't do our experiments in geologic
time.
It would just take too long.
So we use proxies to get,
let us attain kind of a movie.
Uh,
it's something that we sometimes call
four d seismology.
Well,
a 40 seismology really means that we're
looking at the earth in three
dimensions,
uh,
up down north,
south,
east,
west,
the three physical dimensions of our
real world and sort of getting a time
history.
Geologic time occurs over millions of
years.
So he,
uh,
you know,
the lifetime of a single scientist,
he can observe that.
But over the years,
we've developed proxies to replace that.
And we can use seismology,
we can use petrology,
the study of rocks.
Uh,
we can look at the ages of rocks and
various ways we can even use
paleontology,
the study of fossils to get some
indication of what the history of the
earth looks like.
Um,
but the,
the,
you know,
the real,
uh,
incredible thing that has happened is
that the three dimensional aspect of
that problem,
uh,
has really just exploded in the last
decade or so.
Um,
you know,
seismic instrumentation used to be pen
and paper,
uh,
used to have these rotating drums with a
pen that would wiggle every time and
earthquake waves passed for example.
Uh,
but right now we of course would record
that digital and that's like the move
from analog tape to,
to cds or dvds.
Um,
so that's one,
one element.
But the other is that,
uh,
you know,
we used to have to wait for an
earthquake and we didn't have very many
instruments in the ground,
just a couple of hundred a,
but now we can put thousands of
instruments into the ground.
And so we get a much finer picture,
much more highly resolved picture like
as if you,
we had been shooting through cheesecloth
or a gauze or vaseline or something like
that.
We,
we,
we've never been able to really see the
earth and all its clarity and now we
can,
um,
we're part of a project called Earth
scope,
for example,
which is like a giant high resolution
telescope,
not pointed to the universe,
but pointed down into the earth.
Uh,
we know less about the earth really than
we know about the universe at this
point.
Uh,
but this telescope is just giving us
fantastic images.
We're starting off with the North
American continent and our hope is that
over the next decades will be doing that
around the earth as well.
Bell earthquakes are a weird kind of
phenomenon in the following sense.
Um,
when we talk about the theory of plate
tectonics,
the,
the working hypothesis is that it's a
smooth motion of the plates,
uh,
that the plates move over geologic time
with predictable rates.
Uh,
it's as if they're,
uh,
kind of a slow movement of traffic,
if you will.
Everybody sort of moving at a rate that
stays constant in time.
But obviously earthquakes happen.
Earthquakes predominantly occur where
the plates interact with one another
along what we call plate boundaries.
Obviously,
uh,
sometimes those plate boundaries or
sideways like we have in the San Andreas
fault or the earthquake that happened in
Haiti.
Uh,
sometimes those boundaries are
compressional like what happened in
Chile or what might happen off the coast
of Seattle.
And,
uh,
sometimes those boundaries are what we
call extensional.
Uh,
best example of this would be the basin
and range and the western United States,
uh,
around the longitude of Salt Lake City
going all the way west to the Sierra.
Uh,
so those three types of boundaries sort
of describe what,
how the plates inter interact,
but earthquakes,
of course,
anodic continuous process by any means
there really what we call a stick slip
process.
So while the hypothesis of plate
tectonics or the working model is that
the plates move,
uh,
at a relatively constant rate at the
boundaries,
they stick and they slip a,
the boundaries don't move at a
relatively constant rate.
Instead the boundaries stick and when
they stick,
the movement of the plates stresses that
boundary and eventually that stress
overcomes the strength of that boundary
and it breaks.
And that breakage is an earthquake as
sort of our,
what we call the stick slip model or a,
we have other names for it.
But that's basically what happens.
Um,
the problem that we face as earthquake
seismologist is that sticking and
slipping is almost a chaotic process,
not quite,
but almost.
And so it's very difficult to predict on
a day to day basis over geologic time.
Of course,
it's very predictable.
We can get an idea of where the active
plate boundaries are a those plate
boundaries,
of course our major faults in the earth.
And,
uh,
we know where the earthquakes will
occur,
but because we can't predict the stick
and slips cycle very well of certainly
over human timescales,
uh,
we can't really get what we call a
prediction.
Uh,
but there's a deeper understanding of it
that that allows us to forecast instead
of predict.
And by forecast,
I mean,
well first of all,
we know where they occur because we know
where the plate boundaries are.
Um,
but we can get a sense of what the
probability of an earthquake might be in
two ways.
One,
by looking at the past history and if we
have enough earthquakes,
we can sort of get a statistical model
of,
of wind and earthquakes might occur and
that gives us some probability.
And the other is to actually do a bit of
forward modeling and actually take the
plate motions,
take a model of,
of the friction along the plate
boundary.
Uh,
take a model of how the stress builds up
and sort of predict when and where or I
should say forecast when the next
earthquake might occur.
And it's gotten to the point where we
can probably do that over the span of a
decade or two,
perhaps 30 years.
Uh,
to the extent that we can,
uh,
sort of provide an actuarial table,
if you want to go out and buy insurance
in California.
As a matter of fact,
there is such an actuarial table to help
you determine what your rates are or I
should say a healthy insurance companies
determine what they're going to charge
you.
And of course we didn't have that for
Haiti.
Uh,
we had barely had that for Chile.
but the point is we're getting better at
it.
So,
you know,
one of the exciting parts of earthquake
seismology is that the better we get at
forecasting earthquakes,
the closer we might actually come to a
prediction that is useful on human
timescales.
Whether an unusual in the sense that
statistically it's unusual.
Uh,
you could say it's just a statistical
anomalies,
statistical fluke.
There's no reason to think that
earthquakes are occurring any more
frequently now than they,
than they occurred last year or 10 years
ago or 10 years into the future.
There's no reason to believe that,
and it has nothing to do with global
warming.
Believe me,
that's a question that we often get.
Well,
one of the things we learned
seismologists is that earthquakes and
occurred anytime and any place,
in fact,
they don't even have to occur at plate
boundaries for that matter.
But that's,
that's a whole other topic.
Uh,
but along some of the major plate
boundaries like the Pacific northwest,
uh,
we have evidence of pastor earthquakes.
And that's actually,
it's an interesting thing.
Obviously we didn't have instruments
going back more than about a hundred
years or so.
So we don't have an instrumental record,
but we have a record from a newspaper,
old newspapers for example,
we have a record from some old mission
records,
particularly in California,
Spanish mission records and elsewhere
throughout the western hemisphere.
Uh,
we have very long,
uh,
historical records and China and Japan
and in parts of Asia where people have
been writing things down for quite a few
centuries.
Uh,
but in some places we simply don't have
that written record and we have to rely
again on proxies.
Um,
there are a couple of things we can do
in a place like California or Seattle,
the state,
California first.
Uh,
one thing we can do when we have a fault
like the San Andreas is to actually dig
a trench across that fault.
And when we trench across false like
that,
and you do that,
trenching it at different places,
you can actually see in the disturbed
soil the record of pastor earthquakes,
it may occur every hundred and 50 or 200
or three or 400 years,
uh,
but with very good carbon dating or
other geological techniques,
uh,
we can get a good sense of what that
history is.
And by doing that trenching at various
places along the fault,
we can even get a,
an estimate of the,
of the size of the rupture,
which gives us a way to calculate the
magnitude that then allows us to
calculate the repeat intervals,
say for these very large earthquakes in
Seattle,
or I should say more generally off the
coast of,
um,
uh,
British Columbia,
Washington and Oregon going down into
northern California.
That's a different kind of a plate
boundary.
It's what we call a subduction zone.
It's a convergent boundary.
It creates the cascades and the
volcanoes,
uh,
so we can't trench it.
Um,
but what we can do is look at the
history of uplift on the coast because
every time an earthquake occurs,
uh,
the upper plate,
which is basically the coast of
Washington and Oregon and northern
California gets bumped up a little bit.
And by looking at the sediment Terry
record,
actually sometimes it can go down as
well.
But you know,
at looking at the cinnamon Terry Record,
uh,
looking at the way,
say even trees or drowned by encroaching
water or lifted above the water table or
so on a,
you can get a sense of the history,
uh,
people who look at things like tree
rings or the history of corals,
the ornate corals up there now.
But if we go elsewhere around the world,
we see that these are all proxies for
past big earthquakes.
There's another proxy which,
um,
in particular for the Pacific Northwest
Works and that is,
uh,
earthquakes along that boundary have a
tendency to generate a tsunami.
And when it's an Ami,
propagates moot or moves across the
Pacific Ocean,
particularly a big one when it hits
islands,
uh,
on the other side of the Pacific,
you get what's called tsunami deposits.
It's a,
it's a very turbulent phenomenon,
brings up pebbles and rocks and disturbs
the beaches and,
uh,
you can detect some of those.
Um,
but in particularly for the,
for the particular case of the Pacific
northwest,
uh,
around 1700,
actually in 1700 a tsunami was
generated.
It was recorded in Japan.
And by looking at the tsunami records in
Japan,
both the historical record and the
actual geologic record of that tsunami
modelers have been able to kind of back
project that go backwards across the
Pacific show that the source of that
tsunami was in fact the Pacific
northwest,
and get a good date 1700,
uh,
for that event.
That event looks like to be about a
magnitude nine,
nine and a half.
That's bigger than what we had in Chile
last,
uh,
just a few weeks ago.
Uh,
and it's about as big as the biggest
earthquake we've recorded
instrumentally.
So now that we know that that boundary
can support a monstrous earthquake,
magnitude nine,
we can go about the job of measuring how
fast the plates are converging,
making some assumptions about how stress
is building up and come up with some
sense of what the repeat interval might
be for that earthquake.
And,
uh,
sad to say we're pretty close to the
repeat interval for that earthquake.
So that's a forecast.
It's not a prediction,
it's a forecast.
And thankfully,
at least in the United States going back
a decade or more,
uh,
seattle and Oregon had been well aware
of the potential for that earthquake and
they're taking the appropriate steps.
One would say to try to mitigate the
potential damage.
You know,
we,
we do talk about things like the big
one,
one in a little,
uh,
how big it will be,
what the impact will be.
A curious thing by the ways that it
we're getting better at predicting the
impact of an earthquake,
then we are actually predicting an
earthquake.
Now,
once we know,
uh,
that,
once we have a scenario earthquake for
example,
of a certain size,
a certain location,
our computer modeling really is very
good.
So we can actually,
uh,
with a computer generate the possible
ground motion from a scenario
earthquake.
We know how buildings interact with the
ground and what will cause a building to
fall down.
We even have a reasonable estimates of
the casualties that might arise and,
uh,
the economic damage as well.
Uh,
so we're getting very good at predicting
the damage.
Um,
and we've constructed such a scenario
for California.
And the reason for that is that over the
next few decades,
30 to 50 years,
the chance of having a major earthquake
in California,
uh,
is pretty close to one pretty close to
unity.
Um,
in some sense it's really safe for a
seismologist to say that because
earthquakes happen,
uh,
almost certainly a large earthquake is
going to happen in California.
So,
uh,
I'm,
you know,
I'm not sticking my neck out by saying
there's a good chance of an earthquake
happening,
but the question is how,
where it will be and how big it will be
and that we base on trenching.
We base on a,
base it on very fine measurements of the
crust moving.
Uh,
we have better calibrated models of the
faults and the frictions on the faults.
And so we're coming up with,
uh,
a sort of a community understanding of
what the big one might be.
Uh,
the US Geological Survey,
uh,
a,
an academic consortium called the
southern California earthquake center,
which actually involves seismologists
from all over the US,
if not the globe.
Uh,
I've come together with a consensus
statement that California rupture
forecast as it were.
And the two areas that are potentially
very dangerous are a repeat of a major
earthquake along the southern San Andres
east of Los Angeles,
but still close enough to do
considerable damage to Los Angeles.
And of course in the inland empire east,
uh,
basically along itn and going down
toward Palm Springs,
uh,
there's a good chance of significant
damage and significant casualties there.
The second area is up in the East Bay,
not a repeat of the 1906 earthquake,
which is on the,
which wasn't on this,
uh,
the San Francisco peninsula,
but in the East Bay and long something
called the hayward fault,
really part of the San Andrea system,
but a separate fault that's the fault
that colloquially you may remember sort
of runs right through the Berkeley
football stadium,
the hills above Berkeley and so on.
So,
you know,
cal might have difficulty feeling of
football team with that earthquake
occurs,
but nor predictions of damage there are
pretty severe as well.
Uh,
but again,
you know,
knowledge of what might happen and
particularly the damage that might
happen,
uh,
goes a great way to providing the
political will.
In fact,
the funding to do something about it
can't stop.
It can't stop an earthquake,
but it can build strong buildings.
You can prepare the population and you
can make people aware of what they might
do when they feel an earthquake.
Um,
and there are other steps we can take as
well.
Uh,
you know,
we can't predict,
uh,
we're getting better at forecasting,
but there's also something interesting
called earthquake early warning systems.
And this is something that,
um,
uh,
has taken a while to develop.
But when you think about it is kind of
obvious.
And when we start with the following
analogy,
uh,
earthquake waves that it in earthquake
occurs,
it generates ground motion.
That ground motion leaves the earthquake
zone and the rupture zone in a series of
waves.
And there are several types of waves and
the old move at different speeds.
We've,
you know,
some of our students learned that he's a
primary secondary surface waves and so
on.
And the primary words are very fast.
The secondary waves are slower and the
surface waves are slower still.
What's interesting about that,
that progression is that the primary or
waves though fast,
uh,
aren't very large.
Secondary waves are slower but larger.
And the surface waves slower,
still our largest still.
And so it's large ways that do most of
the damage.
So the theory is that if you could
detect that little bit of a p wave
coming along,
it's not going to do a lot of damage,
uh,
but uh,
might give you enough time ranging from
a few seconds,
a few tens of seconds,
uh,
to,
maybe even close to a minute or so or
more.
Uh,
it might give you enough time to do the
sort of things that would save people
safe structures.
Uh,
you could stop trains,
you could shut off gas,
uh,
you could,
get people to,
uh,
find safe haven inside the buildings for
example.
Uh,
if you could do that,
that would constitute a pretty decent
early warning system.
And so their experiments and trying to
do that,
it's been implemented.
Japan,
it's been implemented in Taiwan.
Um,
and,
uh,
there are,
other countries around trying to,
to investigate these systems.
You know,
preparing for an earthquake is
multifaceted,
multi dimensional.
And the first thing really is being
aware.
Uh,
yes,
I've said that earthquakes and occur
anywhere,
but they're more likely some places than
others.
So you know,
basic awareness of where your house,
where you work,
uh,
where you are relative to the faults
that might cause an earthquake.
That's a matter of public education.
Um,
but once you know what you're a risk
might be,
uh,
you have to make some sort of personal
judgment or if you're a government,
some sort of social judgment about the
level of risk that you're willing to
accept is going to be.
And if you're willing to accept or only
willing to accept a low level of risk,
then there are a number of things you
need to do,
you to ensure that major infrastructure
is resilient,
that our water lines are power lines are
built in such a way so that they won't
break that bridges and highways one fall
down.
That fire stations will remain standing
so that the fire personnel can respond
and that hospitals remain standing,
um,
with respect to individuals in their
homes.
Uh,
if you're an earthquake zone,
ensuring that your building is up to
code,
if a code exists,
um,
ensuring that you follow that code and
even little things like keeping the
knickknacks away from the edge of the
shelf,
keeping your dishes way back.
Those are the sorts of things that could
make the difference between sort of a Ho
hum boy was that an interesting event to
something that was a disaster.
Um,
and these are all written down.
You can go to the fema websites,
USG,
s websites.
There were a whole list of these things.
The problem arises when first you don't
have building codes,
uh,
or those codes aren't enforced.
That was a situation in Haiti where you
don't have the national or social wealth
to actually consider this something you
can do.
I mean,
they're the,
and I don't mean to bring up Haiti
constantly,
but the issue there was that there were
so many sort of day to day problems
facing a Haiti culture in Haiti
government.
That's something that might happen,
uh,
really can't get on the radar screen.
And you could argue the right or wrong
to that.
But that basically is a situation and
sad to say that's tap us throughout the
world.
Um,
so you know,
the basic things really quite easy to do
if you've got the money to do them and
if you've got the public awareness to do
them and if you've got the political
will to do them.
If you're dealing with the Commons,
if you're dealing with infrastructure,
uh,
where you don't have the political will
or the wealth,
uh,
there are a number of things that the
community is trying to do.
There's a lot of concentration on
building small scale community awareness
so that the awareness of disaster,
the awareness of potential disaster I
should say,
uh,
occurs almost at the household level and
enabling people to make decisions but
also giving them sort of the simple
things that they,
that they could do on a day to day
basis.
Uh,
not just for earthquakes but for floods,
for landslides.
Uh,
and for that matter,
for longer term issues like sea level
rise and climate change.
Uh,
you know,
one of the,
one of the key things that we're doing
at our institute and elsewhere is trying
to,
to bring the knowledge we have about
earth processes near.
So dynamic planet.
It's fun to look at.
We enjoy doing that,
but it affects people.
And one of the things we're trying to do
is to bring that knowledge,
not just throw it over the fence so that
policy makers can use it because you
know,
there's none of a feedback and that kind
of a system.
Uh,
we really,
scientists need to understand social and
cultural constraints on using the
information and in fact,
even the utility of the information that
they provide.
And if I may say,
I think the social scientists and
governments and ngos need to know what
they don't know and that's a difficult
task.
Uh,
but to be honest,
it's an interesting and important thing
to do and we're getting better at it.
You know,
she'll use a particularly interesting
earthquake from a psychological point of
view of,
first of all,
of course it's very large,
a magnitude 8.8.
Uh,
so we would call a great earthquake
where we use great in terms of the wow
factor,
if you will.
Uh,
it did kill 700 people,
thereabouts.
It caused billions,
tens of billions of dollars worth of
damage.
So the economic impact in Chile,
he was going to be severe.
Uh,
but we don't get a magnitude 8.8 very
often.
The only reason,
by the way,
there weren't more casualties and chelay
and more damage and chill a's that the
earthquake was off the coast.
It was in the subduction zone.
It generates an Ami as we saw.
Uh,
but it wasn't a direct hit.
but being anywhere close to an 8.8 is
enough of a hit to be dangerous.
And that's what happened in Chile.
But it was the result of a subduction
zone.
It's part of what a seismologist call
this certain Pacific seismic belt
earthquake belt.
It's what's colloquially known as the
Pacific Ring of fire.
Uh,
that's actually a great name because
indeed the Pacific is rimmed is ringed
by these subduction zones.
When a subduction zone means that the
heavier,
denser crust of the Pacific Ocean basin
is essentially diving under the lighter,
less dense crust of the continence
surrounding,
um,
and as it dives underneath that it
sticks and slips and causes earthquakes.
Um,
roughly 70 or 80% of the world's biggest
earthquakes occur.
And the Pacific Ring of fire,
it's,
you know,
it's a gigantic source of tectonic
energy of earthquake energy.
Uh,
the other interesting thing about that,
by the way,
and the reason it's called the ring of
fire is because,
uh,
as he's plates dive down underneath the
lighter continent pieces of the melt,
and that melt becomes magma that just
drives up through what we call the
mantle and the crust and creates
volcanoes.
So it's,
it's kind of part of a,
a,
uh,
an ecological recycling mechanism going
on.
You're taking old crust,
throwing it out,
sending it down the subduction zone,
recycling it into new material,
just like you throw a paper bag into the
garbage or the recycling bin.
Um,
so that's the basics of the tectonic
activity.
Uh,
these earthquakes tend to be very large
because,
uh,
these are,
large plates.
The continence present a significant
barrier to subduction in many cases.
Uh,
and it takes a long time for stress to
build up.
One interesting thing is that we knew
about this,
this problem in Chile of course for a
long time.
And of course the Chileans who have an
extraordinarily advanced and
professional capacity to deal with
earthquakes,
uh,
knew about this as well.
But,
uh,
20 or 30 years ago,
using very simple components of the
plate tectonic theory,
uh,
this particular area was identified as a
so called seismic gap,
a place where an earthquake was
basically overdue.
Uh,
couldn't predict it,
but we could forecast it.
And that's what in some sense,
save Chile.
Now,
large earthquakes do strange things.
Um,
uh,
of course what an earthquake does is,
in addition to breaking the ground,
it actually moves big crustal blocks
around.
And when it does that,
it shifts the distribution of mass of
the earth.
Now,
uh,
because this wasn't an asteroid or a
comet hitting the earth and causing all
these vibrations,
the earth has to conserve its angular
momentum and the way the earth conserves
its angular momentum when crustal blocks
shift like that is to change the rate of
rotation and to slightly shift the axis
of rotation.
It can be calculated,
but it really isn't measurable.
On the other hand,
if you're being paid by the microsecond,
maybe it's something that you might
worry about.
Uh,
but the interesting thing is that we can
calculate it.
Not that it is in fact something we got
to worry about
a hand.
He's a different kind of an animal,
but it,
it,
it pays to think about what's really
happening around South America.
Uh,
the Chilean event,
a subduction event,
uh,
was a seduction of a piece of the
Pacific plate in this case called the
Nazca plate,
but a piece,
a smaller plate going underneath.
I know he Chile underneath the Pacific
Ring of fire.
And so this is a case where the
continent and the Pacific Ocean are
sliding,
are,
are converging against each other in the
Pacific diving down.
Because it,
because it's denser.
But if you look at the northern and
southern parts of South America,
picture it in your mind.
Um,
you've got the Caribbean to the north.
Of course you've got the Scotia seat of
the south between South America and aunt
artica.
And those are two very interesting
plates.
Uh,
you know,
in some sense he can think about those
plates as resulting from the squirt of
material in geologic time going around
South America.
So if you can't sub duct this stuff,
you can't get everything underneath
South America through subduction.
That stuff has to go someplace and it
goes north and south and sort of squirts
around.
And the Caribbean plate is one of these
plates.
I've got squirted through the gap
between North and South America.
Uh,
of course it's,
it's a vast simplification,
but it's actually the way we,
we teach it.
It's kind of a fun thing to think about.
Um,
and so that the Caribbean is actually
itself a small plate.
Um,
it is a significant part of plate
tectonics.
It was will recognize as a plate,
uh,
but it's been basically squirting past
South America between North and South
America,
going from west to east and it's moving
at a little less than an inch a year
relative to North America.
Now,
the unfortunate thing for Haiti is that
for geologic reasons,
Haiti lies along the northern boundary.
And because this is a squirt boundary
going from west to east,
uh,
that is what we call a strike slip
fault.
It's a fault that moves sideways.
There's some complexities to that,
but that fault was also recognized as
being capable of supporting a magnitude
seven or greater earthquake.
Actually 7.2,
uh,
in fact,
that forecast was made in the
professional literature in 2008,
two years ago.
Um,
and,
and we've known for about 20 years at
that fault was dangerous anyway.
That wasn't a subduction earthquake.
That was a sliding earthquake and
sliding earthquakes strikes slipper
earthquakes or dangerous also for a
number of reasons.
Uh,
first of all,
they tend not to be as large as a
subduction earthquake,
but it can be large enough.
Uh,
they also,
in this particular case,
they occurred on land and unfortunately
the,
it was almost a direct hit on
port-au-prince.
The earthquake itself was shallow,
which increases the amount of vibration
that people on the surface feel.
Uh,
and it was very close to major
population centers.
So if you will,
it was sort of the perfect storm of bad
effect.
Uh,
even if Chile had good building codes
and good construction,
I think we would have seen tens of
thousands of casualties anyway,
very difficult to deal with an
earthquake of that sort,
but it was a different kind of an
animal.
Um,
we've looked at the Chilean earthquake
in many ways and we continue to do so.
In fact,
there are a number of conferences coming
up in the next few days,
uh,
to try to move to the next phase of
Chili rebuilding and sort of essentially
make the,
the rebuilding of Chili more risk
conscious,
not just for earthquakes,
but for the storm's coming up and the
annual storm season,
the annual hurricane season and
concomitant landslides and other natural
hazards.
Um,
but you know,
trying to understand these,
uh,
earthquakes on land,
these strikes of earthquakes,
it's a very complex problem.
Uh,
and one of the things that were very
worried about in Haiti is that this
earthquake may have stressed parts of
the fault that did not rupture on
January 12th.
Uh,
you know,
when a,
when an earthquake happens,
it doesn't zip open the whole fault and
only sips open this case about a 40
kilometer segment of it.
And there's still stuff on each side
that did not rupture well,
that stuff may have been overstressed.
That piece of the fault may have been
overstressed.
And so the potential for an earthquake
on those segments may actually have
increased.
That again,
is a computer model.
It's something that we're working on.
Uh,
it is hard to predict,
uh,
but it is something that as a forecast
ought to play into the way Haiti's being
rebuilt.
Um,
Chile,
we could do the same thing,
but to be honest,
uh,
Chile,
apart from the economic damage and the
economic recovery,
Chile has a,
a good capacity to deal with future
earthquakes and the outcomes of this
earthquake.
With Haiti.
Uh,
I hope that the international community
will work with the Haitians to build
that capacity so that they can monitor
the potential for these future
earthquakes.
Well,
you know,
obviously the public has a great
interest in earthquake happens and so we
do our best,
best we can.
Uh,
the questions tend to be repetitive.
Um,
almost always we get a question from
somebody about whether they can come see
the Richter scale.
Do we have an example of the Richter
scale?
Uh,
the Richter scale is a mathematical
calculation.
In fact,
psychologists don't use it anymore.
The only reason we give a rector of
magnitude,
frankly,
is for the press and the media.
But we have much better ways of
measuring the energy of an earthquake
now.
But the second question that's cropped
up and,
um,
it's fascinating in its own right,
is that,
uh,
the first time I heard it,
I thought it was a fluke,
uh,
but I've heard it so many times since
Haiti that I wonder what's going on.
And that is,
are these earthquakes related to global
warming?
Uh,
I'm serious about that.
I,
I'd say that most of the press and most
of the public that have called in that,
that didn't have specific domain
knowledge,
uh,
has asked us that question.
Uh,
we also get questions whether,
you know,
uh,
2012 is coming a couple of years early.
Uh,
we get that sort of thing.
It's just the end of days.
But I think it speaks to something more
interesting,
which is that,
uh,
earthquakes and major disasters,
have a certain impact on the public
consciousness.
And I think earthquakes more so,
or even volcanic eruptions more so than,
than anything else.
Uh,
you know,
we get a major hurricane,
a few major hurricanes every year.
We get floods every year.
Uh,
their major disasters that cause more
norms,
amount of economic damage and
casualties.
Uh,
but yet we hear about them relatively
often.
And so we kind of think of that as kind
of background.
This is what the earth is doing to us.
But earthquakes,
especially major ones,
are relatively rare.
We get a few major ones that decade,
uh,
particularly ones with huge numbers of
casualties and the concept of an
earthquake,
that it shakes the firmament,
that,
that it removes your footing,
that it could destroy everything in a
blink of an eye.
And that it is unpredictable,
that it just happens.
Uh,
even if you're rational in a scientific
way,
uh,
even if you're a rational and even a
theological sort of way,
you get to,
it has to have some impact.
Um,
you know,
the,
the response,
the scientific response to the Chilean
earthquake,
all the modulator,
it a bit by the damage and by the
casualties still was this is a major
earthquake.
We've got to look at this as well as we
can because we only get a couple of
shots of decades.
Look at it.
So now there are teams of scientists and
lots of instrumentation going to Chile.
Uh,
but when you get down to Haiti or
something like Haiti,
uh,
when you get a directed on a capital
city,
when the bulk of the nation is affected,
where you have damaged that far exceeds,
uh,
their economic ability to come back.
Uh,
coupled with the fact that an earthquake
literally moves the ground on which you
cited a,
you start asking basic questions like,
should I even be here?
Should I be living here?
Do I have to move?
What is,
what is the future of my country?
What does the future of my city?
And those are the sorts of questions
that I think have such a big impact on
the public that,
uh,
by necessity I think we've got to talk
about them.
We've got to talk about what it means.
I think science is somewhat ill equipped
to do that.
We,
we quantify everything.
We enumerate the energies,
the displacements,
the ground motion.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
we have technology and we have lingo,
but none of this relates to somebody
who's asking the question.
Uh,
my house was destroyed.
Where should I move?
Uh,
and it relates of course in a very
quantitative,
scientific way.
But how do you,
how do you approach that person?
How do you assure them that the
situation has a rational response?
And I don't think we have a good way to
deal with that.
So a lot of the questions we were
getting and a lot of the,
uh,
the thinking that generated,
had to do with these central questions
of what does this mean in particularly
for the future of Haiti?
But what does this mean when we talk
about taking steps to mitigate against
future tragedy,
future disasters,
not just for earthquakes.
So for the other major natural disasters
as well.
And uh,
to me that,
and too many of us,
I should say,
uh,
it's not that we haven't thought about
this before,
but it seems to me to be an area,
not just of research,
but of so sort of a way to link directly
to the public directly to the people who
need to understand what it is we're
doing as scientists.
Uh,
you know,
I could,
I could make the same sort of arguing
about climate change for example,
but,
uh,
earthquake serve,
I use a phrase,
and I don't mean to use it lightly,
but,
uh,
earthquake service training days for the
major environmental disasters,
major environmental stresses that our
planet faces.
And if we can begin to address how we
relate to the public,
how we provide assurance,
how we,
uh,
help the public to understand what it is
that happening in them.
If we can understand how to do that for
major earthquakes or major hurricanes a,
then perhaps we can do something about
stuff that's even more merger,
the major more in the future,
more emergent,
uh,
more probabilistic,
where we actually might have a chance in
modifying our behavior to do something
about it.
So
what I've taken away from this
interaction from Haiti and it's,
and Chile and I must've been,
it's not new to this earthquake.
We've had it before with the Indonesian
earthquake and the Indian Ocean tsunami.
Uh,
we've seen it in earthquakes going as
far back as the 80s and the 70s,
and places like Armenia and China.
And so on.
But what we've taken away from this,
um,
is that there's a conversation that
scientists have to have with the public
that the public will regard as deeply
meaningful,
which means we can't just throw our
results over the fence.
We can't just stick with our technical
journals.
There's gotta be some other mechanism.
And
in my view,
I think universities where,
uh,
we ascribed to liberal thinking,
the small l liberal,
uh,
you know,
we ought to better,
it'd be a good place to do it.
Uh,
and I,
I think the universities have that kind
of role to play beyond the roles that
governments and other social
institutions play.
Yeah,
no.
Uh,
it's the rarest seismologists as hasn't
experienced an earthquake.
We call them theoreticians,
by the way.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I've experienced earthquakes,
uh,
nothing larger than about a magnitude
six.
Um,
and of course I've been an aftershock
zones where magnitude fours and fives
are fairly,
fairly frequent,
uh,
and you take steps to deal with it.
Uh,
but it's very difficult for me to
imagine what it would be like in an 8.8.
I mean we,
or even a 7.0,
that was a direct hit.
Uh,
I personally feel fortunate that I
haven't been in that.
And I sometimes joke with my colleagues,
that's why I work in New York and not in
California.
But on the other hand,
um,
you know,
we understand earthquakes in the
abstract and the visceral feel of an
earthquake is something that perhaps
might contribute to the conversation we
need to have with the public.
And maybe there ought to be a program to
get a lot of seismologists into
earthquake zones that they can
understand what it's like.
I'm,
I'm only half of specious there.
Uh,
but to experience an earthquake is to
know what it means to somebody who may
not be a seismologist,
who has a house,
has just been destroyed,
who has a livelihood that has
disappeared,
uh,
and has a government that's in shambles.
And,
uh,
maybe all we can do is extrapolate,
but I think it's,
it's something necessary to think about.